meet rody Smith a 25 year old internet
superstar from Florida since he started
high school he's become an undisputed
master of the frisbee no target is too
small or too far away for Brody I've
been playing frisbee for about 7 years
now so I would have to probably say over
my lifetime I've probably found easily
close to a million times but in 2011
Brody pulled off this most epic throw to
date with this monster 500 foot effort
off the Narrows Bridge in Perth
Australia this never before performed
throw earns Brody the 15th spot on our
countdown where its mixture of skill
coordination and execution I had a
little little patriotic tear when I
realized all this was going down in
Perth Western Australia now I've
actually been on that bridge it's windy
up there and not only that but it's a
long way up the wind was coming off my
back right shoulder and as far as the
frisbee is concerned when you throw it
it always wants to try to be level so I
wanted to make sure that I put the edge
on it like this to where the wind was
gonna push it to make it level what's
happening is this frisbees moving to you
and the arrow is traveling a further
distance on the top than is on the
bottom which is creating a low-pressure
zone up here and that's causing lift on
this frisbee so that's what's keeping it
going up as it's going along but
normally the frisbee if we were just
pushed through the air would start
tumbling but that's where the spinning
comes in if something spinning it
doesn't like to be tilted it doesn't
like to change its momentum so the
moment you try and tilt it it resists
that tilt you can't spin a frisbee too
fast faster it's going the more stable
it will be and it will hold this
perfectly level pattern for pretty much
as far as it can keep going while
spinning so while we enjoy Brody's epic
throw one last time watch this space
because we have a feeling this won't be
the last time the internet sees a clip
of Brody's fantastic frisbee flinging